pas tous vendredi 9 février bienvenue
dans le 7-8 l'hebdo c'est l'émission de
tv
soixante dix huit pour revenir sur
l'essentiel de l'actualité
départementale de la semaine lé titre de
cette édition
la neige a fait son retour ce vendredi
dans les yvelines toujours en vigilance
orange et pendant cette période toutes
les têtes sont forcément tournés vers
météo france qui délivre des prévisions
comment la situation va-t-elle évoluer
comment l établissement est immobilisé
en ce moment nous recevrons à christophe
vincent de météo france est le conseil
régional d'ile-de-france des ménages de
à paris en seine saint denis hassen
point les services ont pris leurs
nouveaux quartiers cette semaine un
transfert voulue par la président de la
région valérie pécresse pour faire des
économies
reportage et puis le reste de
l'actualité une semaine forcément marqué
par les chutes de neige dans le
département elles ont impacté le
quotidien des yvelinois et des communes
mais aussi des entreprises qui ont
fonctionné au ralenti reste avec eux on
parle de la neige dans un instant
c'était la promesse de campagne de
valérie pécresse déménager les
asservissent de la région en banlieue
parisienne la collectivité elle loue
actuellement cinquante mille mètres
carrés de locaux dans paris pour plus de
30 millions d'euros annuels à ce
déménagement va permettre de générer 9
millions d'euros d'économies par an est
la présidente de la région a présenté ce
nouveau siège situé à saint-ouen en
seine-saint-denis cette semaine
reportage de via grand paris elle assure
elle même la visite
valérie pécresse présente le nouveau
siège de la région ile de france au
revoir les beaux quartiers parisiens où
les deux mille agents étaient dispersés
sur 11 sites différents
bonjour saint-ouen en seine-saint-denis
où les services sont regroupés dans cet
immeuble de bureaux de sept étages à
deux pas de la station mairie de
saint-ouen un déménagement très
symbolique
y'a pas un bon et un mauvais côté du
périphérique on revient on
viens dans un quartier populaire la
région centre dans les quartiers
populaires et dans leur réalité
ensuite un avantage économique
[Musique]
évidemment 9 millions d'euros par an
d'économies sur les loyers c'est
beaucoup et sur la durée et bien ça nous
permet de redonner cet argent en aide
sociale en investissement pour les
lycéens en investissements dans les
transports d'ici fin février ils seront
1400 agents à investir le nouveau siège
du conseil régional
ils vont découvrir un bâtiment lumineux
et spacieux avec de nombreux points de
restauration ils vont surtout prendre
possession de leurs nouveaux espaces de
travail en mode open space désormais ils
vont devoir aussi s'habituer à des temps
de transport pour certains rallonger la
région a donc décidé de leur permettre
de télétravail et on va proposer à 80 %
des agents de télétravail et un ou deux
jours par semaine
on en a 6 ans qui depuis janvier sont
passés en télétravail donc ça veut dire
que vraiment les dossiers on les fait
plus tôt à la maison et quand on vient à
103 ans c'est vraiment pour pour se
rencontrer pour échanger pour faire des
réunions de travail etc
ce déménagement se fera en deux temps un
bâtiment est en construction en face de
l'hôtel de région il abritera le futur
hémicycle où les élus votent les grandes
décisions
un 1300 policiers 500 gendarmes
supplémentaires d'ici 2020 dans 30
villes et 20 départements prioritaire le
ministre de l'intérieur et gérard
collomb a présenté hier la police de
sécurité du quotidien promesses du
gouvernement
parmi les quartiers pour la reconquête
républicaine 13 concerne trap est
notamment les merisiers les squares léo
lagrange henri wallon et la commune à un
apport sur le terrain pour renforcer la
lutte contre le trafic de stupéfiants et
le pôle de prévention du commissariat un
référent dédié mis en place pour
dialoguer avec les bailleurs enfin des
réunions de contact se tiendront
régulièrement avec les trappistes
aussitôt parti calais a déjà revenu dans
les yvelines ce matin la neige est
tombée est de nouveau ce vendredi dans
le département première chute vers 10h
l'alertent orange neige verglas a
d'ailleurs été prolongée jusqu'à demain
10h au moins vigilance sur les routes il
est conseillé toujours de ne pas
utiliser son véhicule personnel côté
transports s'était encore perturbé
réseau de bus stopper des trains au
ralenti trois sur quatre par exemple sur
les lignes n ai eu la situation peut
bien sûr évolué jeu
invite à consulter régulièrement les
horaires de vos trains sur le site du
transilien et beaucoup d'événements
également annulé 1 ce week-end tenez
vous informés via les sites internet de
vos mairies alors côté météo de la neige
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça va se
poursuivre d'autres épisodes sont ils
prévus la semaine prochaine on va poser
la question à notre invité christophe
vincent bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
adjoint de la division prévention de la
direction de prévisions prévisions
prévision de la division prévisions de
la direction interrégionale
ile-de-france de météo france alors
c'est forcément la question que beaucoup
de personnes se posent on va commencer
cet entretien par là comment va évoluer
la situation dans les prochaines heures
alors dans les prochaines heures en fait
la perturbation qui nous a concerné
aujourd'hui fini sa course et ce hors
d'île de france
dans la soirée la halle de finir sa
course actuellement sur la seine et
marne pour partir vers l'est
la neige n'est plus d'actualité par
contre la vigilance est maintenue
puisque au gré des éclaircies même si on
a encore quelques petites averses à
quelques flocons encore qui pourront
nous concerne et là rien de bien grave
ce qui va être important c'est la
nouvelle chute des températures puisque
le redoux n'est pas encore d'actualité
il doit s'établir en doucement et on
attend encore des températures entre -5
et -8 encore sur les yvelines qui vont
favoriser les phénomènes glissants
d'où notre maintien en vigilance au
moins jusqu'à demain matin donc c'est
vers ce week end et des températures
encore très froide alors pas très froid
les températures redeviennent positives
makwaia je dirais la journée par contre
elles restent fraîches la nuit et au gré
de deux perturbations qui vont nous qui
vont nous concerne et une dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche qui sera plutôt
pluvieuse et une autre dans le plus tôt
vers la journée de mardi qu'il y aura
peut-être quelques flocons vont amener
un lent redoux pour arriver 1
j'irai ce qu'on appelle le vrai redoux
mercredi où on va retrouver des
températures légèrement supérieures à la
normale ou dans la normale donc redoux
la semaine prochaine un nouvel épisode
n'est pas tant rien rien d'actualité en
corée ce niveau là alors si on revient
sur la perturbation justement neigeuse
qui a touché l'île de france cette
semaine
comment on peut l'expliquer d'où
vient-elle finalement cette perturbation
neigeuse
alors on a eu de phénomène on a eu une
remontée neigeuse qui occasionnait
toutes les toutes les neiges abondantes
celle de la nuit de mardi à mercredi qui
nous ont donné 13 cm je crois un peu un
peu en dessous de ce qu'ils avaient eu
en 2010 ce niveau de trappes et des
cumuls un peu plus important sur sur le
reste des yvelines et après
l'établissement mais je dirais d'un
régime d'ouest où on revient avec un
régime aux techniques mais sur des sols
très froids et sur une atmosphère un
traître air for adhd cette perturbation
j'irai après la côte où elle était
pluvieuse est devenu très vite neigeuse
pourrait être entièrement neigeuse géré
à partir de l'heure et après à ces mises
à traverser comme prévu j'irais là la
région mais pour venir se rajouter un
peu de
mais c'est aussi l'annoncent maintenant
d'un nouveau régime océanique d'accord
et de températures un petit peu plus
douce
et justement cette depuis le début de
cette perturbation neigeuse la
préfecture des yvelines est en alerte
centre opérationnel départemental
toujours active et avec tous les
services de l'état serge morvan préfet
des yvelines dresse un premier bilan au
micro de nicolas bendriss toute cette
coordination que nous avons dû mettre en
oeuvre s'il n'y avait pas eu cela les
conséquences auraient été pires sur
l'a86
qui arrive sur la n118 donc là ça a été
difficile parce que les conditions
atmosphériques qui étaient vraiment très
difficiles et de ce fait dans des
endroits vallonné la difficulté a été
réel les personnes sont restées
évidemment trop longtemps bloquée et ça
s'étonne c'est un point qui doit nous
amener évidemment à
à être collectivement meilleur sur ce
traitement là il ya eu d'autres points
moindres quand même mais noir important
c'était au niveau du triangle de
rocquencourt sur l'a12 et c'était au
niveau 2 des départementales 196 et 307
au niveau de l'accès à l'a13 entre
versailles et saint germain en laye donc
ça voilà ça c'est les points
d'amélioration 1 et christophe vincent
rendre passer à la suite est ce qu'on
peut parler d'événement exceptionnel
vous faisiez référence tout à l'heure à
l'année 2010 où il y avait eu aussi
également de grosses chutes de neige
jusque là cette année on parle de
également de d'événements exceptionnels
on peut qualifier cet épisode neigeux
surtout celui de la nuit de mardi je
dirais qu'il y aurait une durée de tours
entre cinq et dix ans d'un tel épisode
donc c'est pas un épisode rarissime
c'est une neige abondante
d'accord mais nous ne sommes pas très
habitués c'est vrai que sur paris dès
qu'on a des cumuls assez importante
la côté l'aspect économique rend vite le
dessus et et paralysent souvent là la
capitale et on aura l'occasion de le
revoir dans cette émission reste avec
tout christophe vincent va revenir
justement sur le déroulé des événements
de la semaine par rapport à la neige
[Musique]
et face à l'épisode neigeux les
collectivités se sont organisés dès
mardi au moment où ça se complique et
les services voirie ont tourné à plein
régime notamment ceux de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines et de la
commune de montigny le bretonneux
reportage de marie lehn iapichino
camille lambert et mélanie poquet
prudence sur les routes évinoise
l'épisode neigeux annoncé par météo
france s'intensifie pour permettre aux
véhicules de circuler sur les 200 km de
routes de la métropole de saint quentin
en yvelines
les saleuses sont en pleine action
[Musique]
puisque les routes ce sont aussi les
trottoirs qu'il faut dégager dans la
commune de montigny le bretonneux
on suit attentivement les prévisions
teintées rouge
donc ça veut dire que c'est pas bon
signe mais c'est pas parce que c'est
rouge que c'est dramatique
la commune réalise une véritable veille
météorologique grâce à un logiciel très
précis jusqu'à 11 heures du matin demain
il va neiger sans cesse pour le moment
les prévisions ne sont pas si alarmante
entre 17h et minuit
il va tomber entre 1 cm et 1 cm 3 de
neige à l'heure et comme les sols sont
très humide donc la neige
elle va pas forcément tenir les tableaux
accompagnés des images radars permettent
à la ville d'anticiper hier après-midi
les abords des crèches et des écoles ont
été préparés toutes les équipes du
service technique sont mobilisés depuis
7h ce matin opération salage 90 tonnes
de sel sont en stock des réserves qui
sont les mêmes depuis deux ans j'ai cinq
personnes hagen human de petits engins
motorisés
et sinon on est douze équipes de trois
personnes sur toute la commune pour
resaler tout ce qui est écoles crèches
dégager des passages piétons dégager les
arrêts de bus et dégager toujours
l'homme au moins un trottoir sur de
l'opération se poursuit demain pour les
différents services techniques de
l'agglomération et avant que tous soient
déneigées
certains comptent bien en profiter je
précise à nouveau ce reportage a été
réalisé mardi et vous l'avez vu par la
suite la neige a bien tenu au sol le
mercredi par la suite alors malgré la
mobilisation des collectivités les
préconisations aussi des autorités est
les yvelines ont connu de grosses
perturbations pour certains la neige a
rimé avec cauchemar d'autres ont profité
de la météo pour s'amuser résumé avec
aurélie ronces patrick jacques de
dixmude et nicolas landry avancée de
quelques centimètres pour ensuite se
retrouver à l'arrêt pendant plusieurs
minutes
voici la situation vécue hier soir par
des milliers d'automobilistes yvelinois
trois quatre cinq heures voire plus pour
parcourir quelques dizaines de
kilomètres seulement
certains ont même dû abandonner leur
voiture pour passer la nuit dans des
centres d'hébergement
urgence et si ce matin vous aviez choisi
l'option transports en commun pour vous
rendre au travail
voici ce que l'on pouvait entendre
je cuis
7h30 chitour donc c'est gagné bah on
attend ibère qui devrait dans 5 minutes
normalement il n'y a plus aucun bus qui
circulent il n'y a pas de taxi alors car
l'arrêt qui se faisait il ya peu avant
midi et a du coup c'est un peu le seul
moyen qu'on avait situation compliquée
aussi ce matin pour ceux qui voulaient
malgré la neige prendre leur voiture
[Musique]
on va essayer de trouver une solution
mais bon pour l'instant c'est difficile
pour rendre cette situation la moins
pénible possible les agents des queen de
50 en yvelines sont à pied d'oeuvre
comme ici à montigny le bretonneux ou
encore à maurepas dans le cadre du plan
neige de la ville les agents sont
mobilisés depuis 5 heures ce matin il
des guerres les axes principaux et
secondaires pour faire en sorte que le
quotidien ne s'arrête pas et j'en
appelle aussi la responsabilité des
propriétaires parce qu'ils peuvent aussi
déneiger devant chez eux jusqu'à un
médecin quand au pas de leur porte
et pareil pour les commerçants ont fait
des appels aux voilà pas le civic
donc je pense que c'est une démarche
collective pour réussir de passer cet
épisode neigeux la manière la plus
simple possible
cet épais manteau blanc devrait tenir
encore plusieurs jours
une galère diront certains d'autres
préfèrent relativiser et profiter des
charmes de ce paysage de montagne on va
se promener un petit peu on va se
balader pour profiter quoi et c'était
prévu de ne pas travailler
et puis va du coup bas pour pour les
petits va ça fait des heureux
et toujours avec moi plateau christophe
vincent adjoint de la division
prévisions de la direction
interrégionale ile de france et centre
de météo france alors on l'a vu avec les
reportages précédents des services de
communes qui ont été fortement mobilisés
pendant ces jours compliqués dans les
yvelines voix à météo france
à quoi a ressemblé cette semaine on
imagine aussi que c'était compliqué de
votre côté à notre niveau gironde a été
obligé de renforcer les effectifs et de
doubler les effectifs le chef
prévisionniste ce régional a été a été
doublé du fait aussi de multiples de
multiples sujets puisque on est aussi
géré on est parties prenantes sur sur la
circulation des aéroports sur les
phénomènes de grand froid sur les fans
de neige qui nous a valu bas beaucoup de
rendez vous avec différents articles de
cutter d'état et notamment la zone de
défense est l'ensemble des préfectures
d'île de france c'est ça une zone de
défense plusieurs interlocuteurs au sein
de cette zone de défense auquel vous
prenez par vaux c'est ça oui en général
le premier interlocuteur le point météo
et quand on écrit ce sommet théologique
ces zones de défense et des réunions
quotidiennes réunion téléphonique creek
quotidienne alors effectif renforcé du
coup là la mobilisation en ce moment à
elle et comment à météo france
là on est revenu dans une situation un
peu plus normale
gérer un effectif et un armement normal
par rapport à la situation sur les
prévisions comment sont-elles réalisé il
ya plusieurs stations météo dans l'île
de france comment commence on fait ses
prévisions tout des phénomènes je dirais
importante digne de la vigilance si on
aurait géré au niveau régional au niveau
de notre division où sont décidés des
couleurs de vigilance ans après après
entretiens avec les chefs
prévisionnistes de toulouse sur les
différents scénarios puis derrière son
lancer des alertes et des bulletins vers
les autorités et vers le grand public
via la vigilance à côté 78 le centre
météo de trappes quel rôle à leur fils
dans le centre météo trappe en fait est
rattachée à nous la région va s'occuper
d'une partie des départements d'île de
france et le centre de trappes aura la
charge bazire est d'avoir des relations
plus particulière avec la préfecture des
yvelines et la préfecture du val d'oise
et une forte mobilisation aussi du côté
cette semaine des secours de nombreuses
opérations menées sur le territoire que
mercredi à bonal dans le sud yvelines
avec gendarmes et pompiers et camille
lambert et mélanie poker étaient sur
place
il est 15h à bonnel les hommes de la
gendarmerie de saint-arnoult viennent
d'autoriser deux camions à repartir ils
avaient été déroutés il hier soir de
l'autoroute
comment dans des situations comme
celle-ci vous en connaissez
régulièrement annoncée des épisodes
neigeux comme celui ci est assez
exceptionnel effectivement puisque mes
gendarmes sont mobilisés depuis hier
environ 15 heures et ont travaillé une
grande partie de la nuit
effectivement pour différentes missions
ça représente combien d'hommes sur le
terrain à peu près alors cette nuit par
exemple où l'épisode neigeux a été le
plus important trente militaires de la
gendarmerie du sud yvelines a travaillé
sur ce secteur il est 15 heures passées
l'assistance peut être véhiculé terminer
quelle est la suite pour vous avec les
températures qui vont baisser cette nuit
oui effectivement la mission est
quasiment rempli mais nous restons
vigilants pour nous sommes toujours
mobilisés bien entendu pour nous assurer
de la viabilité des axes des principaux
axes de communication dans tout le sud
il vit n'est donc même dans tout le
département
les militaires ont effectué une
quinzaine d'interventions depuis le
début de la nuit des interventions
possibles grâce aux agriculteurs aux
communes mais aussi des pompiers comme
ceux de rambouillet
lamarre
lieutenant vous venez de faire une
intervention qu'est ce qui s'est passé
alors un poids lourd s'est retrouvé
piégé donc sur la commune de rochefort
en yvelines dans une pente
il s'est retrouvé piégé il a glissé
s'est retrouvée bloquée donc contre un
poteau et un arbre en voulant se dégager
le poids lourd a percé son réservoir de
carburant
donc on s'est retrouvé face à un risque
de pollution du reiki et est située
juste au niveau du pôle eaux a donc
l'idée de manoeuvre était de pomper le
carburant qui ce qui restait dans le
réservoir environ 700 litres est donc là
on a un attentes des pompes pour
réaliser la manoeuvre pour pouvoir
évacuer le poids lourd ensuite sur un
garage paulo quand tu y fais ce temps là
on se doute déjà les pompiers sont
appelés pour de l'assistance à la
personne des voitures qui perdent le
contrôle et ça aussi c'est une mission
peut-être qu'on connaît moins oui alors
là on n'est pas sûr de secours à
personne mais sur deux
moi plutôt protéger l'environnement
d'une pollution donc ça qui fait partie
intégrante de nos missions puisqu'on est
en campagne donc les délais de route
vu les états de l'état des routes
aujourd'hui est encore augmenté donc
c'est ce qui nous fait perdre énormément
de temps cette intervention aura duré à
la journée le verglas est attendu pour
la nuit les secours conseille de ne pas
prendre son véhicule alors vous l'avez
vu dans les précédents sujet malgré les
risques annoncé beaucoup avaient pris la
route mardi soir et était resté bloqué
sur l'a12 notamment encore aujourd'hui
on a pu voir en circulation avec
quelques voitures avec les nouvelles
chutes de neige les retours à la maison
ont pu s'annoncer difficile or si vous
comptez braver tout de même les
préconisations de la préfecture écouter
les conseils du capitaine et dick lebeau
commandant de l'escadron de sécurité
routière des yvelines il était notre
invité alors de notre édition spéciale
mercredi dernier train concernant le
premier c'est de ne pas se déplacer avec
un véhicule personnel c'est sauf si
nécessaire mais vraiment extrême urgence
le deuxième c'est d'anticiper son
déplacement c'est à dire prévoir des
délais supplémentaires d'équiper son
vécu six ans portant avec des pneus
hiver neige aurait que des chaînes et
enfin si on est sur la route adapter sa
vitesse et faire anticiper les sondages
alors si la voiture patine il faut
éviter de rouler en première mais plutôt
en seconde d'accord ça sera plus simple
rouler avec des voitures à des feux de
croisement pour être bien vu et pour
bien voir ce qui se passe et avant une
vitesse ce très modérée alors conseil
côté circulation de votre côté
christophe vincent quels conseils vous
pourriez donner à nos téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent pour ce week-end je
dirais de ne pas banaliser les alertes
météorologiques et de se renseigner au
niveau météorologique au travers en bas
de tout ce qui est diffusé autour de la
vigilance de consulter notre site
internet de vigilance sur lequel en cas
de couleur orange voire rouge
on trouvera des bulletins de suivi on
trouvera une chronologie des épisodes
pour essayer d'adapter son comportement
est aussi c'est circulation je te
rapelle vigilance orange ça à simply
quoi finalement c'est vrai qu'on a plein
de couleurs déjà lancé plusieurs niveaux
la vigilance verte va gérer verte n'y a
pas de yar yann particulier jaune il ya
une petite attention particulière parce
qu'il pourrait y avoir un risque orange
on va avoir un suivi spécifique de
l'événement parce qu'on s'attend à des
phénomènes qui vont être importants
voire dangereux et rouge c'est le sait
le stade ultime où les phénomènes où les
zones et sont encore plus importantes
dernière chose alors on nous parle
vendredi 9 février à 16h37 la la
vigilance elle est maintenue au moins
jusqu'à demain samedi ça oui il en faut
au moins jusqu'à demain 10h très bien
merci beaucoup christophe vincent
d'avoir été avec nous le rappelle vous
êtes adjoint de la division prévisions
de la direction inter régionale ile de
france et centre de météo france et vous
pouvez retrouver bien sûr un tout les
les prévisions de météo france sur le
site qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci d'avoir été avec nous est la neige
et le verglas ont aussi eu des
répercussions sur les entreprises de
saint quentin en yvelines des salariés
elle ne pouvant pas se rendre sur leur
lieu de travail certaines activités qui
tournent au ralenti
quelle était la situation hier jeudi à
saint quentin en yvelines nicolas landry
et quentin le frère ont dressé le bilan
7h30 ce jeudi matin sur le site
challenger bouygues construction de
guyancourt les premiers salariés
arrivent en voiture ils sont plus de
3000 à travailler ici
ils ont bravé la neige et le verglas
malgré les conseils donnés par la
préfecture de limiter les déplacements
véhicule on a essayé d g la voiture et
puis comme ça roulait à peu près on a
pris la voiture finalement
mais déjà hier je suis pas venu
travailler parce que les routes étaient
pas praticable ça c'est une chaussure et
ce matin les accès étaient bien dégagés
j'ai la chance d'habiter près d'un axe
le roulant ce qui fait que j'ai pas eu
de problème sur la route les nationales
sont très dégagé juste la bretelle on a
vraiment sur le rond point là
leur emploi des cendriers sinon tout est
dégagé si le site de challenger semble
retrouver une activité normale cette
entreprise unis monteyne du bâtiment est
au ralenti impossible pour ce chef
d'entreprise d'utiliser ses véhicules
bloqués par la neige et le verglas
le gel a tout bloqué ils sont pas
conduisible pour lui la journée se
poursuit dans son bureau sur ses onze
salariés de ont pu venir travailler ce
matin des difficultés entraînant des
retards sur les chantiers et la perte
d'environ 15000 euros sur le chiffre
d'affaires j'ai un seul salarié sur un
seul chantier aujourd'hui qui fait le
travail qu'il devait faire c'est à dire
aujourd'hui appliqué des enduits et
penser moi j'habite dans le centre-ville
donc j'ai pris le camion et puis j'ai
roulé tout doucement jusqu'au chantier
quoi ce restaurant anticiper les
intempéries et l'annulation des
livraisons des produits ont été stockés
avant l'épisode neigeux
on a quand même réussi à ouvrir un on en
a eu beaucoup moins de clients que
d'habitude à environ un tiers un tiers
voilà la préfecture d'île de france a
mis en place une cellule d'urgence pour
les entreprises impactées par les
intempéries
à l'heure actuelle aucune structure
yvelinoise n'a fait de déclaration pour
cet épisode neigeux
les reportages de nicolas landry quentin
le frère j'ai oublié de le préciser
aussi de patrick jacq de à dixmude de la
culture à présent et pour refermer cette
émission la bd qui ne craint pas la
neige cette semaine à des barea
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bubble sky
c'est le festival de la bande dessinée
pour cette deuxième édition le thème
c'est le manga reportage de marie lehn
yapi chinois après le succès de la
première édition les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines veulent
transformer l'essai le mois de la bande
dessinée devenir le festival buggle sky
et l'agglomération adopte la culture
japonaise du manga sur la durée du
festival
il y à des expositions des ateliers de
dessin dans les médiathèques vous pouvez
retrouvez la programmation sur le site
internet des médiathèques
on reçoit aussi des portraitistes manga
qui peut venir vous croquez façon manga
dans plusieurs médiathèque de saint
quentin et la programmation riche des
cinémas entre manga film japonais les
cinémas indépendants se sont donc
ajoutés aux festivités en créant même
l'exploit le grenier à sel est l'un des
rares cinéma français a diffusé le
célèbre manga akira le 24 février pour
jouer le jeu jusqu'au bout la
médiathèque du canal a transformé son
auditorium en manga qui ça ces salons de
thé japonais conçu pour y lire ce manga
tranquillement mais avant de profiter de
la vue sur le canal enneigées petit tour
par l'exposition
on a aussi la chance de travailler avec
le conservatoire des arts de montigny le
bretonneux et donc cette année
le professeur de bandes dessinées
monsieur jean pierre a fait travailler
ses élèves autour du manga à notre
sollicitation
voilà et donc du coup et on a une très
jolie exposition sous forme de stickers
de deux planches que compte travailler
ses élèves donc de 6 à 77 ans le
festival buzz sky se tiendra jusqu'au 4
mars dont toutes les médiathèques et les
cinémas indépendants de l'agglomération
c'est la fin de cette émission le 7-8
l'hebdo est à revoir sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
et 78 excellent week-end à tous et
n'hésitez pas à profiter ce week-end de
la neige pour vous amuser
[Musique]